looks like we may have done it maybe
yeah we done did it hello what's up
still sending to twitch apparently hi
how y'all doing Thank You Anthony
um today I'm playing animal crossing i
wanted to i have this one part of my
island that I've not known what to do
with so I wanted to build basically a
Pokemon gym in it let me throw it up on
the stream if I can the kind of idea of
what I'm trying to build here would be
plus image okay and find the image on
desktop this it just fit immediately
great great quick okay cool cool cool
cool yep
that is what I'm trying to make is it
back it should be any minute now
catch up buddy here we go yeah so I have
this open area that I was gonna try and
make a nightclub it didn't walk it
didn't make sense I'll make a nightclub
in a room in my house
but I'm basically trying to build this
exact thing like I'm gonna need to make
some some custom floor patterns for it I
think which is gonna suck because I'm
not very good at that I've done a little
bit of it but that is the plan so I'll
make this smaller well but just sort of
leave it here for reference I also
haven't played today so tell me Theo got
is too loud I don't have headphones in
so I can't hear the switch but you guys
can
did I play dreams and do I recommend it
I recommend dreams so highly oh my gosh
it's so cool yeah definitely play dreams
man
you have those full patents Treena saxon
if you do i would love them if there's a
place where I can get them hit me up
because I've actually not put any custom
patterns in the game so far I'm not even
done that the custom stuff that I have
is stuff that I made myself which again
not very good at because I've never done
any kind of pixel yeah oh man why don't
I play telling lies on a stream I feel
like that's a terrible game to stream
it'd be very weird what I'm talking
sounds like audio is fine this is my
first stream with no technical issues
what okay yeah I haven't played today so
that's why she talking to me cool great
love that for us weird dog thank you
appreciate it
I am gonna do an island to a video
probably this week because aside from is
one part my island is completely done
everything is anything I haven't today
right now so my stores I've been for the
first time so that's exciting
it just was up for renovations two days
ago I took a really long time I don't
know why the island name quarantine II
will age well and you know why that is
my island name for him he didn't you
catch that oh look how cool it is in
here now it's because I doubt I'll play
it much later in here when we're out of
quarantine so I feel like I put all this
time in and built this island during the
quarantine so I think it's just gonna
make me think of that is the idea
cool cool cool this is great I'm glad we
have more stuff and this is stuff I
haven't bought before I have that what
is this
let me get money for it that's the best
I don't think I have one of those either
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah give it to me
give me all of that oh my gosh I don't
have one of these I will take that too
yes please I have some stuff to sell to
you guys don't I let me go back to my
house I think I have some bullcrap to
sell
they've got cool-looking new tools and a
wallpaper as well yeah my house is not I
don't have much going on in my house so
I'll go in there because you guys have
to see the storage but listen the island
is the main okay the main attraction
here the house itself
garbage am I allowed to say what the
next f-h Animal Crossing video will be
yeah it's more Island to us
yeah this is supposed to be like a
bedroom area this is the kitchen which
you'll see has nothing going on it's
just kitchen stuff didn't do much the
house don't care okay I do have garbage
to sell though so let's go what did I
want to sell these yes yes yes yes damn
you damn you pockets you can go to
storage I want most of this stuff I
think you can probably go in storage
yeah we don't care about you at all
[Music]
I'm not gonna need any of this really
for the purposes of this dream to be
honest well I mean I could just get rid
of you good show storage it is then you
can also have on storage okay
sell more junk yes yes yes yeah it's
been a really long time since I even
went to the store
cuz it's always closed it's a pansy in
here now oh well my bad
all right go sell some stuff no I still
do not have lights again don't care
about the house
okay I don't care all I care about is my
Island which i think is very legit
there's like a couple more things that I
want to do before I will make a YouTube
video of a full tour of my own Island
when it's fully done like one thing I
want to do is change these pathways to
like a concrete of some kind did the
person in the chat news book about
having like the QR code of the Pokemon
gym get back to me cuz I would love to
be able to use someone else's customs
than using my own but here we are I do
have a poop at yeah the fossils scooter
man gaming I have because yeah my my
thing's been closed so I just put him in
my inventory they renovated just now I
started playing this game a fair bit
later than everyone else
all of you can go I think I only have a
limited time to really buy that thing so
I'm just gonna go get some money out I'm
not rich because I slept through turnips
this week so that's my bad hello Matthew
Sierra thanks for saying hi oh it's a
Saturday hi Kay Kay star rating I've
been at five stars for like three weeks
and I know this is the ultimate hyung
humble brag but also is genuine I've had
a five star rating since before I even
tried
I didn't even know it was a thing that
you was supposed to care about until I
went and asked Elizabeth and she was
like great five stars and I think the
reason that that happened for me is
again because I have not paid any
attention to my house I've only paid
attention to the island my island is
stacked is virtually no empty space so
because of that I think that's how I did
it really easily so for anyone who's
having trouble it's all about you
putting how much money was it 130 let's
just take out take out oh I'm gonna take
out 50 because I have a bridge to pay
off to that I think I'm gonna demolish
oh it's not enough anyway I'm bad at
math and extra 58 what I wanted
confirm let's go buy that [ __ ] and
put it in the kitchen maybe take a quick
look at no chopping see what you got
same stuff I've always had cool cool
cool cool cool
all right I don't know if I'm too
awesome with my Island decorations I
just again have a boring house most
people did it the other way around
three twitch streams going at once but
on the nose oh thank you
manly scream I appreciate that planted a
bunch of flowers yeah that would
probably help again I also have a lot of
flowers like you know it's just very
populated I just have a lot of stuff I
don't think it pays that much attention
like way you put the stuff or anything
it's just having it if they like I just
wanted to buy this but dad didn't know
if I can customize it I probably can't
can I
yeah Sivan I just said it he's a
five-star Island I will give it to her
eventually so I'm gonna show you guys
what it looks like that's not the point
I did one time drop down to fall because
I have too many flowers like this
sitting around they count as like items
just sitting around being dirty because
I guess it doesn't identify them as just
items I also do have a lot of weeds but
I'm just trying to try to make my cool
island am i playing on PC sure AM
yeah my favourite PC game animal
grossing 77,000 for a pool table mm-hmm
weed so effect Island rating there you
go that's cool yeah eventually I'll fix
this garbage but you know that's what we
got things to do and making a kitchen is
not one of them labyrinth said I love
how girls say they a game is and then
show us playing this really yes you're
right go plays Animal Crossing
immediately invalidates all gamer cred
that's a good point that's a good point
so let me jump over to the island oh the
area in question show y'all what is up
I'd still need this goddamn tail for
this I have one in the museum but I just
need to finish that tail this is my
graveyard up here which sucks
it's like my least favorite part I keep
trying to grow black flowers but it's
not working
they just keep spawning more red and
transformed black and I was told red
next to red whoops why I've got one
black rose but that's it but keeps one
more red I'll keep holding out I guess
I'm shooting I'm doing the right thing
haven't looked up any tutorials
so we go up my red carpet I did custom
make this flooring it's not very good
this is the area that I'm going to turn
into the Pokemon treatment which means
getting rid of all this wall crap
and then hopefully copying this art that
we see in the bottom corner here I'm
making it work don't know if I'll be
able to do I think Animal Crossing would
have done as well as it has if it wasn't
for Ovid absolutely not
I probably wouldn't have played this
game if not for Kota well I probably
would have a little bit I did play a new
leaf a little bit but not as much as I
have no way it is white boy yes train
isackson how does a create a code walk I
die again I don't have any custom stuff
that I'm actually using stead of like is
this a like is there a website I go to
Damian has a lot of like flowers I'll
reach out to him in awesome yeah I got
rid of my nightclub ultimate Greg which
is this area cuz I don't like it
it didn't walk outdoors I couldn't make
it happen so I heard about and I'm
replacing this Pokemon gym and when I
get in upstairs to my house I will make
that the nightclub because right now
like I have all this garbage out here
that I moved we don't talk about this
it's fine don't worry about it you know
I should do my chores first
before we start the renovations let me
just pick up some shells and sell them
there's my campgrounds it is
intentionally full of weeds supposed to
have that outdoor camp and feel you know
how it be over oh that's fun I love that
great video game 10 out of 10 10 out of
10 you dig it alright
please be something I don't have I
actually don't know dude do definitely
on the rest of that great quick like a
cool cool cool cool
alright picking up shells game of the
year can't wait till I get stopped
playing this stupid game are you shake
that tree I think um I'll take you Stein
thank you thank you now
thank you Greg but my nightclub is not
looking cool what I say is my favorite
video game genre I'm probably
action-adventure I do love an RPG bug
I'm also love a third-person cozy
shooter so there's a few of them big fan
of all of the video games really
whenever people ask me what what kind of
games do you play which I get
surprisingly often I don't know I want
to say like obvious variety of stuff
that I play but it's difficult to
quantify that unless you watch it like a
scroll through my content or whatever
but um no I do play absolutely
everything are you right there mate
let me so do the shells so can you like
much but it's fine I'm gonna clean it up
gotta clean up what games do I play
daily nothing I play all the different
things would I give hunt showdown a
crack already have you know it have also
already played war zone I do love horror
games a lot yes my favourite game is a
horror game thank you for the comments
on play which listen uh there any genres
I dislike listen I don't really screw
with RTS is very much I actually have
played a number of them but I'm just not
very good at them
yeah my brain just struggles with 90s so
I don't play a lot of that kind of thing
these are all just my public benches
that's fine we I'm worried about it
ooh what's the town tune I'm not gonna
tell you yes you definitely know what it
is
did I try Valerie yeah I've played a
fair amount of Valerie I do really like
it I was really bad at the start we've
got a little bit better a few I was in
so the fact that I feel like I learned
really quickly is really appealing to me
I need to fix this gap at some point
stuff needed last night nope there it is
[Music]
thank you Michael
yeah I basically um whenever I describe
my island I say that I think it's sort
of a theme park I didn't get inspired by
anyone the Pokemon gym is the first
thing I've done because I saw someone
else do this so I was like I want to do
that but really it's just been like I
have sectioned areas kind of again like
a theme product this is a decision I'm
very unsure about to have a bridge here
I mean it incline don't know that it was
the right call
I'll demolish it if I don't like it but
I put it here because this is where
Redlands when he comes on this secret
beach but I can't put two there because
the the down there is just like that
crappy you like beach rock so I don't
know we'll finish it see how how we feel
about it
but this is the longest I've left an
incline without finishing it because I'm
like right I also kind of wanted to open
this place up a bit though because
having too many trees makes it hard to
even really see what's going in did I
try out the made a maze you know what I
think I missed it did that end today I
think I might have missed it which is a
huge bummer but yeah I don't think I got
it
yeah it's always always here cuz I
didn't see you anyplace that I have any
open space Thank You bury you buried and
home eight Thank You aerobic people do
tell me that I have a calming voice all
they tell me that I'm really boring it's
one or the other no I
I definitely think a thing that annoys
people want on YouTube is that I don't
like overreact to things when people are
used to that they take it as me being
very unenthusiastic whereas really I'm
just much hill self am I gonna be able
to dig this up I don't know that I am i
I don't think this is diggable I'm gonna
have to build to be a take that ok
Animal Crossing you stupid video game
yeah I guess I have to thanks man
yeah I know if I bury 10k I get more
bells I just don't care cuz I don't
really need bells so I just always
buried the same lot I know that's just
uh an Alana ISM I'm just like man I'm
just always gonna bury though the thing
that I dig up it's fine I don't mind
it's easier and I don't have much need
for money I guess maybe I will now
because I just upgraded the store and
stuffs more expensive something they'll
have to change that scrap but previously
I've just
[Music]
don't care about my house also the ton
of exchange just makes things very
simple alright alright again really not
sure if we want back there I might like
it I really don't know I don't know
we're just gonna have to wait and
[ __ ] see AMI
guess we'll find out okay just hit every
single tree on the way out perfect
get these fossils assessed and then
we'll get to construction
I think boring and down to earth can be
perceived as the same thing I don't know
[Music]
let's go let's go let's go
t-rex tail come on hold it out for you
ooh
Maxwell Costa asked have what did you
think of the Clone Wars finale I am NOT
up to date I am just about to finish
season 5 so I have not seen it and I'm
trying to avoid just information about
it like the plague my hair is such a
mess and used vaguely try and pat that
[ __ ] down it just happens I just have
very fluffy hair um
wait I wasn't reading what you were
saying bro okay you have nothing on my
person that you can accept at this time
whatever whatever whatever whatever but
do you have a t-rex tail no I'll take
the dinosaur track that's cute that's
cute see what it looks like I could put
it somewhere I'm into that dinosaur
track
oh I expected it to be footprints like
just visibly on the ground I'm sure if I
flip it it is but I like that a bit I
could maybe display that here somewhere
I throw off the symmetry though isn't it
no it's fine it's fine I don't need it
am i enjoying what I've seen so far up
to season five yeah I think one was
fantastic
next time I talk to Troy Baker tell him
his hair is from the gods I think he
knows a compliment Troy 20 surely he's
aware okay take all of my fossils and
also some fruit and eggs thank you get
money get paid man that's what I'm
always saying you know just getting
money getting paid all right plant this
thoughtlessly cool and then go to
construction let's do it I wish I hate
you bother me
this is my I don't know if you guys have
heard I decided he's a pedophile so this
is my Islands local pedophile
Vladimir we do can't shame him not the
island is not supportive of his
tendencies
it's not my fault he moved in next to
the playground and spends too much time
hanging out there waiting for children
so you know if you're gonna act
suspicious expect reactions that's all
I'm saying
did I make a cameo in the movie the hunt
mind in a way that I can't completely
Zelda theme yes it's a huge let me jump
up and girl is top [ __ ] first do I
think that Activision with the stall was
licensed will produce anything
interesting like a clone ones FPS game
No
demolishing and delayed is [ __ ] down
figure out if I can custom it it seems
unlikely but we'll try oh boy
what kinks does quarantine II support
any but pedophilia really is fine
[Music]
that would be limitations potentially
but for the most part we're okay do I
stream on Facebook a lot max I think it
this is probably my third time streaming
on Facebook for that point asking um it
is offset this on my stream i am
currently streaming on four platforms
makes it twitch facebook and youtube and
chats are all combined on rain streams
and it's not difficult for me to keep up
with all of them they're all on the same
page real simple I like doing it because
I've built up audiences on different
places and it seems crappy to be like oh
I know you have to go watch me on this
specific platform when I can just be on
all of those platforms tear people away
from the place that I first got their
support or whatever we drink white
clover Bly what a weird thing to do
I do also drink beer right now only have
what
and it's very refreshing and also less
calories which is a benefit oh man no
that was not what I wanted to do let's
get rid of all of this garbage I like
that the problem Jim is so close to the
cemetery this the down sweater point on
one hand you could send a Pokemon and
dying and going to the cemetery on a
second hand you could say it's so funny
11 - 10 11 - it's gonna say 11 - City
definitely 11 - tone I do drink via I do
not smoke cigarettes streaming rocket
Lee sure seems unlikely but I would do
that at all why not not against it you
just scream whatever I feel like playing
at any given time I'm totally honest
[Music]
why not be away not cigarettes again I
do drink beer do not smoke cigarettes
why would you if you had the option not
to I'm an asthmatic so I kind of really
beautiful do anything that's cool
probably not probably not anything that
we considered cool some people consider
DJing cool a lot of people really hate
it but that's that's much better way
than I thought that's fine with me you
fall into the water again it's too far
away it's fine good day I have the gyms
to build anyway I don't care
I have played by luring yes
did I play Ari yes I loved Horry
I will of the whist was so good
like I I don't think they fix fix all of
the the bugs yet which is a huge bummer
because a friend of mine was played at
recently Trisha Hershberger and said
that it did crash for her on se hitches
such a shame otherwise okay I hate that
you can only do this one at a time yeah
it sucks
alright body just chopping it all down
so this gym is probably gonna be the
sand right I think we're not decent
custom scales some custom what Evers you
know I think I might up up didn't mean
to do that
got rid of old I know if you know kids
in a bulldozer that would be so legit
I don't care doesn't even want my money
so this is probably too long right now
these are like what is that in the
picture one two three four five six
squares but these squares are not gonna
be equal to the Pokemon squares all I
know is that there has to be a little
space here for a person to stand I think
I'll have this be a concession area and
then maybe here's where they stop
playing and then this will be like this
if you play a one this would be well
trained of two and then this will be a
bunch of seats I feel like that works
we'll have this like maybe gated off a
little bit soon do I want to have them
sitting on grass in this image they're
all standing I don't know what would I I
feel like it should probably be stun
which I think I need to get custom for
I'm gonna like just do this live on
stream well I could push it closer to
the waterfall I don't think I need to
think if I run up here this should be
enough space like I feel like right now
it's too long that's why I'm thinking if
have all of this be concessions and then
yeah if I need to add more on the back
end I can do that but what are you doing
this game you build stuff
no whites-only science no no points for
that Lindsay did make her in jail that's
the best I have the Nintendo app but
wait all the custom patents on the
Nintendo app I thought they were like on
websites and then I would use ice candy
key Walker right right yeah I think so
I'm not actually sure websites okay
let's see if I can find if someone who's
made already Hey okay Animal Crossing QR
codes sucks I'm just gonna look that up
and see what happens cuz I this is this
is me I'm new to this it's gonna have to
be new horizons so many of them whoa we
have cool Star Wars once this is all
very cool do the doom cover odd what is
that oh my gosh make yourself look like
a Bulbasaur it's a little Team Rocket
outfit
what oh my gosh
I like that that's a cute that pop get
me some of that QR codes for all their
animal Crossing's they work with me
horizon though but uses the creative
codes and stuff now we're all wait so
that means I can't scan QR codes into I
don't know how it works
so I can't scan the QR codes into um
that app is that what is that what you
say
Zoe telling me you can import them in in
your essence
what are you telling me I don't know how
creative codes worked Reena Saxon I
appreciate that but I don't even know
how to do it if you use a QR code you
can't edit it ok that's cool with me
that I just smashed the keyboard it's
fine everything's fine I'm gonna see if
this app lets me scan because this is
genuinely my foray into this you can't
with your phone and it's one at a time
cool um ok game specific services great
oh wait wait no don't you have to scan
it into you can scan QR knapping up to
import one at a time
with the Nintendo app ok yeah I have
that mmm so designs scan QR code here we
go soon
yep it's in the frame it's in the frame
scan it you [ __ ] is it she's not gonna
work hmm nothing happened
that's fun it's not apply to face cutout
standees it shouldn't just walk
shouldn't it why did that not happen
image quality too bad maybe I don't know
you need an app on IRL go to horizon and
at the Nook font in game wait what go -
I'm on the correct thing I believe oh
look at how the green is keyed out Oh
it'll be on that right now you say I
have doubts
in custom right this is just old stuff
that I build got my eyebrows which is
also my town flag like the top one I
just read a walkthrough really shouldn't
I I don't have a MUX on my channel I
mean you were just dreaming
yes quick one you want to overwrite
okay change design is that what you're
telling me the beer and then what
audios choppy I don't know why I don't
know why that would be happening that's
very weird last time I just had to close
I beat us an opening again which I don't
really want to do again am I excited for
next gen no I don't know maybe my audio
fixed itself I have no idea what
happened
can't you all creeper let's try it again
okay
no that just doesn't want to walk after
got a table sisters you say fine I'll
just not I'll just do it myself it's
fine that's what I was expecting to do I
don't care probably this whole thing's
gonna be sand right maybe some snow
around the outside the boldest replaced
when I figure out how the [ __ ] that
works it'll be fun we'll make it work
again I'll see how it looks and I'll
adjust if need be
nah my inputs perfect something wrong
with my input it doesn't say it's just
stream broke no reason I can try
what this happened last time don't know
why is it that bad or tolerable it's
actually very bad let me hear it cuz
lost something like I said I have to end
the stream in song again which was just
a huge bummer that's annoying I have to
do that for YouTube purposes alright at
least that's not that is pretty bad no
idea why that would be happening
no idea don't know how to fix that I can
just stop like the ice and start it
again
mm-hmm
this should fix the audio problems hello
everyone I'm back
he's my audio okay now again just OBS
did that last time to just work things
for no reason for anyone who just got
this notification hi I'm building a
pokemon gym as seen in the bottom left
of your screens right now is basically
the plan for what I'm building in this
one area of my Island that doesn't
really have anything going on I don't
know how it's gonna look
will play around with it we'll figure it
out but it's the last point space that I
have so I'll see what we can do
wait
okay I don't like this I'm definitely
gonna want to change this I just don't
like the stone coffin general I feel
like it needs to have edges and the fact
that it doesn't have edges bothers me
okay we'll make it work all of this
stone and now because if you keep my
cool it happens I don't want to talk
about it and then you just put our way
to a benches back here and that's kind
of a start that's not gonna work it's
gonna tell me there's no space brilliant
video game it's learning cool
well not quite what I had in mind should
I push these closer together are you
gonna go closer together or didn't think
so all right probably want to change
these colors eventually [ __ ] you there
is room you can make room
okay I know you can great out here I've
got some stuff that I feel like I think
I have like one of the drink stands
never mind
I don't disregard oh we could put a
light out here though
to light up the playing field did not
mean to pick you up sir palm tree back
in your hole okay I need to fix this rub
fence to my habit
can I do that my accident a boom I feel
like this should also be rubbed off but
I'm gonna have to reconfigure some
[ __ ] he had to make that work
all right studio spotlight I'm gonna put
here
Chow and also you can't go there nope
gotta be better off we'll figure it out
later
just get the sand down okay one step at
a time
Ashley said I wish you could do a group
row while : instead of doing it
individually Ashley there are a lot of
things I wish I could do in this game
that I can't just a lot really you know
game not that good that's my repeat and
what take game not that good okay that
was all supposed to be stone that's my
bad you gotta swap back to the stone do
me outside first it's done it's done
it's done nope
here we go we've got it anything in that
fake direct if you guys haven't seen it
that fake direct was so well made that
was like such good production value for
fake direct really impressed
yeah they nailed it
[Music]
okay we're getting the foundations I
hate it but I'll figure it out later
I will figure out how to get the QR
codes walking before I do my island - uh
which I think I'll do in the next week
or so in case you missed it we do have a
five-star Island out here ladies and
gentlemen have for quite some time
there are still some things that I need
to change before I'm like sure that it's
like good and done and ready before I'll
do a tour of the whole island so I'll
make sure this is done before then but
this is really like the last difficult
part otherwise it's like get all the
black flowers some minor tweaks okay is
that about the length we would have the
white line with the polka bowl yeah I
think this is about right really just
guessing out here as the best engineers
do the best city plan isn't known for
just yeah it's about right make it work
and then you also to you guys when it's
finished and then I was thinking about
if you guys would be interested in this
doing a island ratings like where I go
to view his islands and rate their
islands but I'm basically gonna make it
as mean as possible would be the
disclosure I will it'll be like a let me
roast your Island stream where if I edit
it down for a video on the channel I'll
edit it in a way that's like listen I
understand you guys have made some cool
[ __ ] the point of this is to be as me as
I could possibly be the only issue with
doing that is that I don't know how to
get everyone's dodo codes without
opening my DMS which sounds like a whole
nightmare I'll have to figure that out
maybe I just like temporarily set up
some kind of a messaging service wait
you can just send dodo codes and just
filter it all but then I would also want
to make sure they all actually are
five-star Islands so our
people to proof I don't know it sounds
complicated I'll figure it out I'd like
to do it I don't want to open up my
Twitter DM that sounds like a terrible
idea
lame and mean like MTV Cribs I guess
yeah but me no I want to be next
this might be too long
might be fine
okay island raids I mean kind of the
same they could post them on disk or in
a chat well yeah but then if they post
them in the chat wouldn't everyone find
it and go to it
wouldn't that be a problem you can maybe
set up a disk or just for animal
crossing maybe do that
[Music]
I can tell it looks like a lot but I
feel like it'll be fun is my point I'll
just have to figure out how to do it
logistically I don't know do i drop
Balor encodes does valor n't have codes
I don't know if that's a thing
I might have to just like have someone
else help me out I have a model someone
like that some stuff okay
exactly he's going gaming that was
exactly the plan it's gonna roast
people's Islands make them feel real bad
for entertainment - okay that is a
foundation I really don't like the stone
it's fine we'll fix it
so now what would it be it would be two
squares of sand but I can't port the
sand can i [ __ ]
this isn't gonna walk I'm gonna have to
I am gonna have to make it from scratch
I don't want to the QR code didn't work
so is he tenderizing meat back there I
think he's just opening things
[Music]
no idea ever going back to my house
since lockdown yeah of course Tom Nook
Pro app for QR codes I need to read a
walkthrough you're all yelling things at
me and none of them make any sense
[Music]
chickity of doom Balor is currently in
beta you need to get a code to get into
the beta the only way to get a code is
to watch balance dreams I guess I didn't
know that because I'm in the Valor
invader and I never got any kind of code
my account just got wait-listed very
nice for me oh I love that thank you
if I don't mind a border of grass you
could draw lines and I believe them on
the sand that's the plan but wait wait
can I though can i overlay on sand
that's what I thought crow Bhd they
don't have codes what streams and you
get listed that's what I thought
influence of privilege come on man I've
been in games meeting from US decade I'm
not in a partner program no it's just as
a media I have the custom design pro app
I can get QR codes I believe I just
don't know how to do it oh that's what I
thought I thought there were no codes
for Valerie thank you for validating me
I did catch a scorpion Mike I quote it
the same way I caught a tarantula I was
not trying on the sneakers up tonight
you can overlay a texture / pattern on
any full pattern okay so I thought it
would replace it so then I can just make
a custom design right I can just how do
i erase those
[Music]
oh this smells really good damn okay uh
did the wrong thing again custom design
do I have to go here no I want to change
it am I missing a button prompt oh no no
no that's right that's right that's
right I'm laying it down I have to do it
from the menu okay my pattern change
design I want to erase everything it's
this one in it and then yeah I'm really
still not sure how to even use these
tools like shouldn't this just do
everything but it doesn't do these guys
which I don't understand why like you
can't just like is there a button just
to blank am I just now eating tonight
yes which is common for me I've been
eating pretty late what's my friend code
gonna share that so this is blank now
correct does anyone know right it is
there's a separate fill all tool I have
to move my face we have to move myself
let me make sure that is crapped
correctly I mean crupp some more of the
right I suppose 100 maybe 150 it's
probably correct clothes grab my face
put me in the middle of the screen which
is about here maybe that's I'm just
gonna assume that that's right who knows
okay
very new to this tool you can make
little stars little hearts that's gonna
be fill all huh okay great Neera mode
swap preview what is this what preview
do don't know
nice line we do want to line we want the
line to be white and we want it just
here really see if this works okay
that's it
what did I do that we need to erase that
it's back to X can I only draw over it
is there an eraser I'm very new to this
that's it wait did I not draw that there
am I am i imagining things okay no so
pen
oh it doesn't I guess it doesn't matter
if it's a pan or if it's just do that
middle one that would be exactly the
same we want to go to white it's just
gonna add the extra line who cares
doesn't make much of a difference and
then x2 don't
plus I mean so I'm gonna go line I think
this is going to be al hi ooh yeah a
loon cool I'm fine with it
a loon loved my white loon beautiful
it's like the opposite of Bob Ross
you're absolutely right it is okay let
us place moon right here wait I have to
face this way see if placing a loon
walks how planned mmm did it not work on
the bottom because it's grass
it didn't okay if I face the different
directions I do it the other way no um
okay so how do I make it thick up
probably a big thick or anyway that's
what she said that seems really dumb
this game is bad
that's my don't take change design more
white I know I can make this shorter for
Prezi all let's just do that no that's
great so close though here we go okay
now let's see if this works
loon yes great looking good I probably
should have made it like three times as
thick but whatever okay
loon still no can I just not do it on
the border because you have transparency
in the image it will form fit right to
the pause you will need to make a right
line head about always gives me eyes man
get out of here Vlada man why is he
dressed that way I didn't tell you you
could dress that way also see how cool
my island is yeah yeah we stacked out
here it's pretty legit I do really love
this area let me just show it to you
guys really I call it to the European
area it's like it's like Holland I think
it's very cute just imagine this is a
like a granary or something or a
windmill I think it's adorable anyway
it's just one little area that's
completely useless in terms of
functionality it's pokemon gym is what
we're doing right now uh so I don't know
why I didn't want what if I try it up
here
yeah that's what I expected it would do
okay do I need to rebuild the whole
thing
is that what you're telling me why is
the white note showing up there which is
where I need it I don't know why it's
not happening very European thank you
thank you I guess it is raining it
actually really rarely rains on my
island it used to be thicker okay always
needs to be thinking it applies to both
women and men to be fair all right just
try making it thicker
loon shame design again make it mad
thick okay if this doesn't work then I'm
gonna have to go QR code route right yes
right on the side this seems
aggressively thick that's not the first
time I thought that it just kind of it I
just the chokes write themselves ladies
gentlemen
oh those lines are there oh it's because
I changed it of course
how does that look I think that actually
looks pretty good compared to that's
gonna have to be a corner so that's not
gonna work anyway so we're gonna need to
make corner bits for those but I feel
like that works yeah yeah I think it's
about the right size if I look at the
image I'm into it I'm just gonna clean
out my nook miles nobody mind me nobody
mind me cleaning a man just eat some
food you know that's what's up do I play
the Pokemon TCG a TCG game to listen I
don't know but I did oh boy did I back
in the day no mmm is this mukbang
I could put Godzilla in the gym that
would walk that would be wonderful
do I need to been whoever my bud Sammy's
who just called me stuck up for no
reason no no it's up to you scooter man
game you see just starting [ __ ] for no
reason that's no really care if they
talk [ __ ] but you know mm-hmm right
people keep saying I know ql codes will
largely immediately from when they walk
in at them and new horizon to me they're
largely for the older way to lay down
pots I mean it would work the same way
though right
you can transfer them I believe it just
didn't scan for me which is maybe just
like an issue with PC brightness or
something I'll figure it out
and isn't delicious mm-hmm why can't I
send you bits
I'm not partnered or affiliate hey
thanks Chevy Brett and I appreciate them
Thank You Ryan
sorry that Daniel this is technically
mukbang this is delicious so you have to
go to the Mabel shop to get people's
parts hmm
no way that's awesome Fontaine it's
Mother's Day in Australia right now
because it's Sunday over there obviously
so I spoke to my mom on the phone for
like an hour and I got her some like
handmade soaps and bath bombs which just
like mostly cuz they looked really
pretty Ashley Jenkins has been posting
all these photos of her handmade soap
and I really want to try it which is
like the most white girl thing I've ever
said but I do want to try it
mm-hmm moms do love soap that's true
meringue the line drawer thing you can
eventually buy as an upgrade in your
resident services
he's very tasty
hmm got it ultimate Gregg thank you
my astray lien English accent considered
broad general or cultivated I don't know
that we really talk about Australian
accents in those kind of terms you are
drama ologists that my mum made me eat
soap when I did a swear a teacher did
that to a kid in my school one of my
best friends James and he he had to eat
soap and I think she was like suspended
for like two weeks because she actually
made him do it as a teacher it was nuts
yeah I'm David the scannings not walking
for whatever reason but whatever thank
you say cold I appreciate that
panorama the door sound is someone in
this department opening a door don't
sound like it's screaming every time
it's happen
I should probably buy oil for it
honestly who's gonna ask if he's tried
but you just bid you can't be making
people eat soap man copy doing that yep
alright before we start building more
pokemon jams see okay women be shopping
said it's true they do I had to drink
vinegar when I swore as a child I didn't
swear I always say this was such a good
kid like I didn't swear until I moved to
a city a big a much bigger place and
then everyone around me was swearing and
I remember I would have been maybe like
probably 14 also maybe maybe a little
bit younger
when I first swore and also my parents
are really chill but yeah I just didn't
do it very young compared to a lot of
people in that area I just didn't want
to I felt like I was disobeying a rule
but now I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] the
rules of dumb oh this is a very gross
dream I'm so sorry okay
we done did it so we need to go back
here gonna go to this one change design
I think I did five layers
someone told me there's a fill all tool
which is this one so we do I could go
the other way I'll learn how that makes
it way easier okay
the line tool works can I make it
thicker though keep editing I don't
think I can so we could do that to that
extent I think I did five I'll have to
check that I'm pretty sure it was five
thickness though and when going here and
here does anyone remember what line
thickness I did I don't recall it was
more than three and only really one
showed up it would be like that right so
I think it's five five five I think it's
fine oh don't know how that happened
okay here we go if it's not five it's
fine I will adjust that's gonna be fine
too even though technically there is no
wine there is only loon
all right cool cool cool cool cool we're
gonna use that one time is that the same
thickness damn it it's not it's one more
thick I think right I think it's six
let's give it a shot but I don't think
it's gonna work yeah it looks like it's
six o beautiful sandwich well now we
know going forward now we know it's six
six it's T I see si si si si si I think
that was six I stopped counting
okay here we go then and done yes
give me my corner thankfully this isn't
hard to make how do I think how far away
do I think Nintendo's and next-gen
console is I don't think Nintendo be
playing those games anymore my dude they
they iterate and will continue to
iterate like when will we get a next
console from them it'll be forever away
how's it still not thick enough did I
not save it [ __ ] did you not save it it
don't look right it don't look right
it's seven fix seven hole fix okay got
it
th I see see see see see see see got it
that's just to get that tiny line it
seems so stupid but it's fine hey hey I
didn't make a game I don't know how to
make video game seems very difficult I'm
sure it was very hard to make this show
up with seven thickness great don't need
to see that every time though because
we're gonna be making a few over here
back to this [ __ ] back to this
[ __ ] and then back to [ __ ]
painting us here just this one [ __ ]
time it's gonna wipe away and I'm just
gonna all right it's getting started
god damn move the corner learn to
another section of the grid what do you
mean
is there an easier way to do this I
don't know that there is though
if there is I don't I don't buy it a
song stuck in my head because I miss the
outdoors they're not even good songs I
[Music]
should let me take down that first
accidental stream I accidentally put up
from the youtubes I don't care if like
the other platforms have vo tees up but
it looks real weird when YouTube has
multiple oh maybe it didn't save anyway
that's strange I'm gonna have to deal
with that later sure something
suspicious happened alright I could make
all the designs first but what if I
don't want to did you consider that what
if I what if I want to do it one by one
fam cuz making the design sucks
[Music]
we are gonna have to make this bit more
complicated though cuz it needs the
space to fit the people right yeah
this is gonna have to go back to bits so
we need two bits of sand yup
you see oh that makes it look so weird
and so thick then out stupid game but
that is how that's gonna have to look
which do I care about that not lining up
with that yeah I do yeah everything's
gonna have to move up it's not gonna
work it's fine it's fine the painting
the down pot is not difficult the rest
of its a [ __ ] so let's know what I
wanted it's fine just fix that
oh that's right that has to go there I
gotta move this over
boy all right that is the correct shape
this has to move also one one do all
right
they're all white around the edges huh
[Music]
yep I hate it it's a chore it's this is
not gonna be the easiest thing in the
world to do just fine make it work
cuz like if I put this across here like
I should that's ridiculous right that
doesn't work hmm I could fake the grass
pattern I think
[Music]
I'm gonna have to figure out what I want
to do here like yeah making the middle
one thinner is probably the smartest
coal but I hate it but so I'm gonna have
to make that'll be the same cone that'll
be the same going on yeah that's fine
okay let's make a thin one for this
middle part I could make them all
thicker but it's whatever I wanted to go
to Hue I can't see anything cuz I can
only see the stream we could probably
make this image a bit smaller let's do
that
it is handy for me to reference but it
doesn't need to be that huge okay change
design back to exfil no we know we can
go the other way that one and then I'm
gonna just do one line I think just one
thickest literally t i th I see see what
happens it's all about art and
experimentation here ladies and
gentlemen I'm gonna call it Juan because
I don't care about the titles I don't
know if that's like I'm committing some
kind of animal crossing crime but I
guess um put me in jail custom design by
picking Juan no no [ __ ] hell so it's
gonna have to be full blank line three
white lines you think okay I'm gonna
trust you person who said that
I change design wall blank three white
okay at least I'm gonna be you know
satisfied knowing I did this myself
right so one two three full blank that's
three three white that was it right I
read that correctly
thank you crime oh I appreciate that
full did I do it right did I do it did I
read him wrong did it sit I did I [ __ ]
it up did I [ __ ] it up
mm-hmm four blank three what that is
correct
let's [ __ ] try it see what happens
okay
that's still want even though it's not I
know what I mean it's fine that totally
worked
great love it love want paint you that
now I'm gonna need to make both of my
corners which are seven thickness I
believe seven seems ridiculous but that
makes sense that's why that was four
plus three right okay why did we erase
mine too
oh we just moved yeah known and we won't
we want line two back I think custom
design line two
well that was an accident excuse me a
second
let me just back this up and boom thank
you hello what do we have here cool a
camp stove one of the first things you
get in the game oh not what I meant to
do
all right back to this I think lying to
a while if I paint it right here
beautiful line too will also work right
here what is that why is that happened
that has happened because this goes the
whole way up but because there's a gap
for the grass sumbitch
I think I'm just gonna have to let that
slide because otherwise I can't fix that
with line to right that goes the whole
way up but I don't want to make the top
line thicker cuz then it doesn't line up
with everything else it's just gonna
have to be that way I don't want to make
Quan oh whoa
could I add to Quan if I go to Quan and
then I just add uh something down right
on the edges I think like if I do this
to Juan okay so what is it fall for the
grass will this work right I think let's
see if this is correct
come on hon come on come on pull through
fam come on yeah I shoulda done it on
both sides I have to do it one at a time
oh [ __ ] okay okay okay okay change only
on the left so does that mean I have to
make a wand too [ __ ] stupid game so
stupid okay yeah I need to make one too
don't I [ __ ] me
okay yep great wait why is it still
there
I can't it's gonna have to be it's gonna
have to be Quan - and then also
on three yeah I'm gonna have to make
just want to that's completely different
so okay change design it's just one - we
don't need a 1/3 fill to this yes
x2 this which is why why it's for up
still that and then for in I think and
then we go down this is Juan - I'm
pretty scary I think I did this correct
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] this stupid
pokemon stadium is fondos brilliant this
better [ __ ] walk okay pull through
for me please Juan dos all right all
right
know it run one it was just the wrong
wrong area there we go yeah we may not
look at us go who's laughing now we'll
wait I have to rebuild this anyway don't
I yeah I haven't built that corner in
any case my god ok ok so that's correct
loon and loot line - and then we need
I'm just gonna make it
corner for the other one ok [ __ ]
alright so to make another corner just
on the other side this thing fell off
then X can you okay here's the thing
folks at some point I'm gonna have to
make the poké ball in the middle you
thought this was complicated and bad
I mean in theory I could just maybe
it'll be fine
I doubt it back here okay I'm making the
other corner which is three up no no no
it's for up [ __ ] for up yeah it doesn't
matter if it overlaps because it needs
to be full thickness right now it's 3
thickness I think I think I'm pretty
sure I'm just gonna call the CCC's who
cares that's gonna be covered by grass
anyway it's not gonna be a problem
that's definitely not thick enough it
was seven it was seven woman it was
seven oh wait no it should it should fit
anyway shouldn't it because the grass is
covering it so the actual thickness
shouldn't matter I think let's see how
you go ah
it took us 40 minutes what we got there
sort of mmm
I feel good about it yeah okay let's
keep going
all right change design why would they
not just have all these designs be blank
anyway is there like something that I
can do to make this simpler X white why
why why it's four in and it is three
thick this whole corner this is just
gonna be uh uh Lou oh I guess that's
fine I don't need to add anything else
to Lou Oh we'll see if that works the
length of the stadium will allow for the
Pokemon to be scented you know I haven't
luo should work we figured that out when
we get there I don't it's not gonna be
hard for me to chop bits off once this
is all built in theory yeah
ah making it happen [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
game alright
Oh brilliant I kind of want to catch
that fish sort of want to catch it okay
that's all we can do here why are you
stuck at two stalls after meeting only
homes if you look at the my homes
they're all like in the same area
they're not in a straight line
sorry I for one who doesn't know Derrick
said I'm stuck at two stalls off to me
often moving my home into a straight
line they're allowed to be in the same
place make multiple copies of a black
square and then go back to go back and
how would that help why would a black
sweat help me I don't understand um if I
talk to my favorite Pokemon ARINC um I
don't care what type of gym it is though
you know it's fine yes wow that was a
Gorgon and I had seen people who've made
like full Zelda and Pokemon Islands it's
really cool I like that my island is
kind of what I wanted to do with it I
didn't copy anything um but I do do that
plenty like copying artists is
replicating on it's a really fun thing
to do in any case a it's I respect the
hell out of it
um yeah again I never had to try to get
stars my island just I usually looked
one day and it was five stars and I
think that's because I have a lot of
outdoor furniture a lot of flowers and
whatever oh I could place the blank
designs first that's true I don't mind
doing it this way though you know we
chatting it's fine great artists steal
I just find like I've always copied out
it's something I find really comforting
like I enjoy just like looking at an
image and redrawing and I've always done
that
Oh in real life too you know redrawn
pots or whatever that's a thing my
favorite Pokemon is actually cha Mandan
or Gyarados in the games it's Garrity's
probably
[Music]
all right is there any benefit to
streaming on multiple platforms as
opposed to just one
no if anything it is the opposite of the
benefit I make a lot less money however
my logic is like if I built an audience
on Facebook and I built one on YouTube
it seems shitty that I would then be
like well but if you want to see me do
this go into twitch I also just want to
limit myself so there's no real benefit
most people would not do it it's why I
feel like I'm unique and I am a person
who does but but no it means I I
actually probably significantly am
restricted by it
because it don't make any money up here
for the other side which why for in 3 up
boom this is gonna be righty-o know how
to get rid of all this first chuck some
righties down cool I'm not gonna fix
Mike it's roit like an Australian it's
on the right side there we go that's
what's up
let's chuck Roy down
beautiful okay can't do the corner gonna
have to build that out separately
managing the chat is not difficult I
don't give it done it's not difficult at
all because people always assume that no
it's super not hard because I have um
they're all in one oh this dream says
I'm playing out of worlds I don't know
why my YouTube's not updated it should
say I don't know crossing let me check
cuz I'm certainly not playing out a
waltz it does Animal Crossing I did fix
it but maybe it didn't save some reason
yeah all my chats are in one window
so like sure maybe I probably don't see
everything but if I'm on one platform
then all people go to that one platform
anyway like every time that I've streams
just on YouTube I usually have 2,000
viewers or so whereas right now I have
you is that are just spread out across
platforms which means that it's the chat
is frankly exactly the same it isn't any
more or less traffic II than it would be
it's just that people have different you
basically all have different logos
depending on what you've said the thing
from okay fixed the YouTube it should
now say I am accurately playing Animal
Crossing thank you I don't know how to
say yo name
maurício I think I'll be able to do it
it's not gonna look as cool as it should
but oh I'll get it there I'll get it
there um do I have any of these corners
built I have this one this is si si si
si si si
beautiful okay now loon is not going to
work because loon four here needs to be
up the top so yeah we got to rebuild all
I'm goddamn cornets
it doesn't take that long
it doesn't take down it's not you're
gonna be fine you'll get through this
it's not that much of a problem X fill
all this is very mathematical though my
brain doesn't like thinking this way
let's not that man but it's more
mathematical than my brain likes
thinking okay four done we're gonna call
you topside top OOP
nope to poke it is letting the typos
happen
Thank You Skaggs infinites I appreciate
it I'm doing well and I'm a little cool
switch to twitch thinking it would
actually make a difference look if you
if there's a preference of platform
I think YouTube's the only one where I
can make any money however and super
chat obviously is a thing there where I
can't make that in anywhere else no I
don't really care what you watch
wherever you prefer it's fine it's not
not an issue but YouTube is the only one
where I can profit but I also like I
said [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] don't care all
right
we can put that there and there and
that's it right that's literally the
sole purpose at that one line because in
the middle it's got to be a different
thickness I think right right right
or is that no that is fine we got the
math down cuz I didn't make it seven
thick quarters okay
yes I do have one of those they are nice
though the poolside but it's very cute
but yeah I have one by my house why does
everyone everyone seen a movie called
ghost Rena I have seen ghost writing why
can I only make money on YouTube never
really looked in streaming over there
I'm only familiar with the twitch cents
scene sorry I can only make money on
YouTube gives asking on the platform
that I am monetized on I do not have it
on twitch because they require that you
sign exclusivity causes which I think
garbage nope not what I intended to do
can't soul it's just gonna make me I
don't have a choice okay cool
well I could go in there and shoot yeah
what's it gonna be it's gonna be called
Rex will throw a Rex down no just sorry
great we will fix you re it's fine
boom change you are going to be my top
left corner all right across yes correct
exclusivity clause yeah if you didn't
already know which makes people sign um
saying that they won't stream on any
other platform at the same time but I
think it's just it's just bad I think
it's not a good yeah yeah yeah dude
that's why I don't have have subs on
Twitch because in order to be able to
partner or affiliate it's not even just
partner you have to agree that you will
only stream on on Twitch concurrently so
I could stream somewhere else at a
different time but I like being I would
stream on all platforms at once so yeah
I think it sucks and it's some crazy
that so many people are okay with that
but I guess like for people who would
trying to make money you know I have the
privilege of with making money elsewhere
I don't have to worry about that but for
me is garbage mmm-hmm put my hours into
fishing then I played The Witcher
do you mean an animal crossing Derek
thank you fat crew I'm sure it has
helped me tremendously do I make money
from views or do you still need
donations from streams okay again I make
no money from twitch so everyone who
watches my streams on Twitch I make no
money at all unless you donate which I
never asked for anyway and I also don't
call out donations it's not something I
try to incentivize because whatever but
I'm having to talk about the business
side of this yeah I make absolutely zero
money from twitch from YouTube
there are ads I think because my channel
is monetized
so yes I will make money and then if the
stream VOD will also have ads on it so
that makes money so that can I mean it's
something much anyway
it's not like it's much money it's
pennies really but twitch 100% for free
which I'm cool with okay good stuff
corner - we're gonna call it Rhett - the
best how am i joke oh one I'm doing
pretty good
it's very hot I did that again let's
name it first then I guess re - fine I
just don't know why this menus they all
have to take so long okay
you're going X film cuz I learned about
that today tool pen I have a pen
I'm going for up [ __ ] Shh
this is re 2l second corner we're very
grateful for your existence twitch
builds brand
does it mm-hmm I think my brand is okay
I haven't found any sponsors for YouTube
videos ghost girl I have plenty of
sponsors for YouTube videos I've done a
plenty of sponsored videos I say no to
all out there beautiful okay there was a
catch for this wasn't there
I couldn't just overlay the same corner
why was that I don't remember
did it get rid of something didn't it
that was right I just had to edit
cool so then we need two more lines that
go across and then up my brain hurts
what am i trying to replicate from the
bottom and try and replicate these ones
so let's it's replicating Quan and Wan
dos all right to fill all don't don't
don't
yeah nope I always press it one too many
times
okay so it's down is it at the top of
them it's at the top is that my brain is
having trouble picturing it wouldn't be
just here again what it what do I have
to do
it is at the bottom or is that just
gonna be Quan is Ho on it yeah I think
it's the top across directly Swan is
bottom it's top and then it's just down
it doesn't matter how many down right is
that right I have to go up you're right
I do have to go up of course they do
because it's sitting on the bottom okay
we have to get rid of this here yeah
here we go here we go here we go that
should be correct for not fun it's gonna
be Jimmy here you go that's that's right
I think it is right yeah you are the
antique Juan okay okay okay okay
got it myself the white clothes were a
bad idea
alright here we go yeah boss and then we
need Jimmy to to hang out with Jimmy one
on the other side to fill up fill the
[ __ ] in it'll go with the pen the pen
the pen and then we go across and we go
oh
for boom uh-huh
still for rent we going up Jimmy - I'm
gonna call it James you know it's the
more formal Jimmy Oh Jay seems really
weird to me that animal Carson doesn't
have more touch control options there's
a take you really can't use the touch
that you can't really use the touch
controls from the touch screen for
anything okay
well that's not what I wanted we wanted
to do it to this one and then this needs
to be back to re to present anything
great okay what get in places now didn't
check if it was sent it I'm gonna play
more ghost run when it comes out for
sure it supports keyboard yeah and I
mean I like that you can use the app if
you want to talk to people when you're
visiting their Islands or whatever I
think that's a great idea but oh thank
you
review he said on YouTube thanks to
doing that podcast discussion on the
McCord and slush team situation of
course I was happy to have that
discussion I really wanted to hear
Austin's take it was very interesting
I'm a music producer and stuff like that
has happened to me professionally and it
sucks which side do you mean do you mean
you alight on something and it was spun
out or like which part of it has
happened to you because it seems like
the situation it's pretty unique but I
don't know if that's that's true yeah
the middle is gonna suck it's gonna be
tough I'm not gonna have a good time
can't wait til she realizes the all
lines of three thick so the middle isn't
going to be symmetrical wait why not
couldn't I just put the three lines in
the middle
mm you're right it's not gonna be
symmetrical it's a good point I can make
the middle fold oh that's okay with me
I'll make them old for I guess Oh been
on the side of having someone closely
behind I mean I have to
I've had that too which for my industry
like I said on that podcast I would just
do the thing for them but trying to eat
less bread
you really get really good bread
it's not pizza pushes bread
it's good day it is good tray I didn't
check he asked is the stadium an even
amount of squares or an autumn out I
didn't check it's fine
I'll fix it just want to get started you
know but yeah actually didn't even look
I probably should make them old folder
rather than three what's the bread name
I don't know it was just handed to me
which part of australia am i from joka
I'm from Queensland the Sunshine State
it's very hot
good [ __ ] bread he's gonna be drugged
though you say that it's living the best
life but this could be drugged you know
um talk it out probably mm-hmm I'm very
happy
good bread all right should I make them
all for thick that's my question I think
I should shouldn't I'm right October 65
aust-r the different accents from
different parts of Australia they're
absolutely all the time is it here
10:08 p.m. Raisa Jim said where does the
hate between Aussie and New Zealand come
from as a Kiwi I don't get it I don't
think it exists
I don't hate New Zealand at all frankly
I think New Zealand is like one of the
best countries in the world but I do
also have a lot of family from New
Zealand do I partake in devil's lettuce
since I'm in California I do not have
never smoked weed never consumed weed in
any way just the Kwan's and James's need
to be for thick see aren't you glad I
named them creatively you're welcome
okay I think no I think it all needs to
be for thick because I would like all of
it to be visible like I understand it's
covered but I want to pull them out one
if that makes sense
do all Australian accents assume things
I think pretty much everyone in
Australia says assume and it's always so
weird to me too people always call out
that I say eschew more consumer or
whatever how do you say the word tissue
are you saying tits you know many people
do that you probably say tissue making
ish sound with an S is not that weird
but um yeah pretty much all of us
trailer does that I don't think all of
us really does hate them
that's maybe just um Queensland I'm not
sure Tamagotchis came back with people
buy them when you were watches if I can
have time ago channel watch I would [ __ ]
with that lady
I think everyone says tissue would sound
right again whenever people like why do
you say assume that way I'm like [ __ ]
how you say tissue though
I still don't know why people keep using
this pea character meme on me but thank
you for the donation she come in they
appreciate it I'm not sure what's
happening in sa we say hatch age you say
hatch I've never heard that no family in
South Australia I think you're lying to
me Jennifer no no I know I know you
weren't calling me out ain't none EMU I
have this thing why because of the way
that I speak I always sound like I'm
angry I'm just like aggressively blunt I
have food stuck in my teeth
we'll make it through oh you say H like
me yeah I think I think all of Australia
maybe says H marshal now look the
balloon go it's fine thank you so I
think advertising will become a
prevalent and free version of stay Diaz
game streaming yes
check my Google stadia video I spoke
about that pretty much at length in that
video about what I'm concerned about
where it comes to stadia despite having
very positive experiences with that tech
America is the first country to laugh at
other nations for accents there are like
10 different dialects in the areas that
I live you live in America it's funny
them the Americans tend to mostly you
think that no one sees a second stream
in a row where I'm told my accent
Australia's only one accent and then I
don't sound Australian
but I do I just don't sound like the
version they used to did I ever come
across a funnel web spider in Australia
never they've left for 21 years before
moving my whole life really no never I
never saw a funnel web but I'm also not
from the state they're from which is New
South Wales okay maybe the oldest really
it does say H Lawrence also talk about
accents cloth stream there you go
Frick's Whitsett as a South Australia
nothing makes me happier when people
describe us as having them a posh accent
I think my accent is the version of a
posh Australian accent despite being
from Queensland people all the time tell
me you know sound like a Queensland
Dameon I really still do what black
flowers yes who says I don't sound
Australian Americans Australians don't
say it just Americans names like well
there's no polite way to like say that
would always be like well you probably
only heard one Australian accent which
is like get I might has a gallop it's um
yeah this does tones of X instead of T
Georgian and I appreciate that
mm-hmm I do have some yellow on blue
public benches I think you can get rid
of them I'll probably customized up at
some point
yikes Samantha that's [ __ ] awful you
are correct an astute al I do not sound
like a bogan and thus people think I
don't sound Australian I do that I do
it's my favorite drink Forex gold sadly
no I actually hate works okay
can you have my patterns bro I don't
even I wouldn't even know how to share
them ok we need to update them to for
thickness James does need to be for
thickness on every front [ __ ] now I
hate myself for this have to update them
all but at least I don't have to lay
them down again it's on this side
and then on this side and let's see how
James looks for fix look at you go James
really getting thicker right in front of
our eyes what happened what happened
yeah that's gonna work Jimmy
let's get you more thick dawg let's
inject some whatever it is that they
inject into women to make them more
plump or whatever what is it you don't
get Botox in your lips do you know you
got Botox to stop you from having
wrinkles what is it what does the lip is
just lip injections does that is there a
name we know for that or we just call it
injections cuz that's what you get in
Jimmy
injected with lip stuff I don't think we
put Botox in lips
great great Phila filler is correct it's
filler you get in filler you beautiful
boston's for free no less I'm doing it
cheap
alright Quan it's your turn I imagine
that shit's expensive
my whole life I have been accused of
having um lip injections since I was a
child which is crazy because actually
when I was really young I got picked on
for it and then as I got older it just
got better and better became more and
more of a benefit didn't like it at
first
collagen mmm collagen is something that
creates elasticity isn't it I don't know
if you inject collagen because I know
that my protein that I take has collagen
protein I don't even know if that's the
same thing you would inject into
something but it's it's very common in
in my workout protein is collagen how
would a kid get lip injections is a good
question I don't know if you can consent
as a child
cuantos Phila not sure if it's collagen
okay I don't need to cancel out make you
wait don't need to do any of this why
did I do that yeah just a pen it's a
pony outside get new full thick right we
did it all right collagen binds to fat
in the lips collagen is what they
injected lips there you go didn't know
but filler is a Huayra clonic acid I
believe
ha-hi hyaluronic never even heard of
that I don't think you just inject
straight fat that seems like a bad idea
but frankly I don't know thanks for
joining Delon appreciate it
sorry with some to some reason talking
about lip filler but somebody's got to
get this boy stick its Lois tongue
let's get you nice and beefy boom at
least this is really fast I've already
laid it all down god I'm so dreading
this
I say it's it's fast it had were elated
all down they [ __ ] up immediately I'm
really dreading the circle
go suck let's not kill my brain
why do I sit on the Vegemite mom might
fence a bold question I'm stuck I kind
of dislike both Vegemite is okay on a
certain circumstances I find mom might
like more tolerable across the board but
I've had it less really overall whereas
like fed you might I feel like a really
thin spread of Vegemite real thin over
but it's got to already be bought it
with some cheese is pretty good just add
some salt all right roit it's done it's
just what's happened to you don't okay
okay this is going alright it's going
alright - PO you also need to be more
thick I believe I'm ready okay done yep
good
what is the purpose of that pokey gym my
pillow smells like Faust there isn't one
no the whole thing is just hang on
who are these bottom boys is it loon
that I need to make more thick maybe it
is it's these two that I think I just
they look really thick and that bottom
corner and both of you okay
oh yeah there's no purpose to this gym
it is not going to have any functional
we need to make you more thick it's just
for appearances because I had this like
empty space in my nylons just one lost
empty space that I was trying to make
like an outdoor nightclub out of but I
couldn't get it to work the funda sure
arrangements were not quite right to
compliment at being outdoors just didn't
look good so I decided to instead make
it a pokemon gym where you can fight
trainers off whatever so that's what
we're doing right now okay great
re - good game good game 2,000 pounds
Phillip Phillip for 12 months listen
people should do whatever they want do
their own bodies but that seems like a
lot just to have slightly bigger lips
but that I guess you know if you're
insecure about it and it would make you
feel better
I assume you're joking but go for it you
know go for it
oh man if I could have the big robot
that would be cool undiscovered I ain't
built that boy yep he's expensive my
some kind of chalk no come on
thank you snarky shocked have I ever
seen Rick and Morty's Buchwald
adventures I don't know I've seen most
of Rick and Morty is that a separate
thing
oh the Straley inversion yes I have seen
that that's probably what you're
referring to I have it did bring me a
fair amount of joy okay we need to do
this bottom left corner which is a line
to really got creative with that one and
then I think it is Luna or whatever the
[ __ ] I called it you go it needs to be
more phil is just like Kylie Jenner Hey
just adding it in making you beautiful
and I think it's lone and I think I
think that's everybody everybody think
okay let's go let's go what oh well I
don't know why I did that
okay okay great
I love that for me
listen the thing with butt implants that
gets me is that if you have like a huge
butt and you don't have any thighs or
hamstrings to me it looks like you're
just wearing a diaper
I just don't I'm not a fan okay I didn't
check if this is equal amount of squares
so let's have a look that's one square
that's two squares that's three squares
that's full sweats that's five six seven
maybe there's no real way to tell
maybe it's seven which would be bad but
I don't know one two three oh five six
seven eight I think it's eight but I
don't know you really need to walk out
the other leg muscles to make it look
proportionate it's not even that it's
like you need to like just gain a lot of
weight dig holes to count that's a good
idea
that's a good idea here we go that's
gonna be one well a duck should have
done that there that's weight but even
the squares aren't gonna be why is that
happening
he's not happening because I have a D
countdown okay so we just can't do the
bottom squares then correct two two
three four five six seven eight boom
accidentally made it even success I
think did we want it to be even well
where's it gonna go I'm gonna have to
then build these mental squares on both
sides to have two thickness right yeah
okay so that's gonna be about here who
knows I think it's gonna have to be two
thickness on both squares but there's no
circle in the middle is there I mean
there's no there's no there's no lying
in the middle this is gonna [ __ ] suck
man no so there's lines on both sides
but not through the middle [ __ ] hell
my brains gonna break I shouldn't have
had the white core I shouldn't have done
it it's a bad idea okay we can make
lines on the sides but even the [ __ ]
lines on the sides are gonna have to
change what these are I feel sorry for
women that have a natural butt shelf
what is that what what is a natural butt
shelf
it's totally possible you in our class
exaggerated it looks natural I just
think butt implants generally look like
you've pooped
diapers because you have this really big
butt hanging little legs and it's just
so obvious to me that like waddling
around with their diaper but like if
again not gonna shame if you did that if
you want that it makes you feel better
go for it I have to make four quarters I
am two on one side and the middle is in
quarters I know what you mean but
implant strong
thank you HP critical that means a lot
but so big you can fit things on top of
it Oh like like Kim Kardashian but shelf
I think house is fake though right yeah
gift for me
I already have that okay I don't care
make full circle quarter patterns yeah I
think you're right for the sides of the
gym outlined press y to remove the
pattern well I'm gonna have to rebuild
the sides is the thing right so like I'm
gonna have to rebuild them entirely to
have their own could I just use the
corners I already have okay so like if I
it's about here
wild guess right yeah
can I not just put the corner here which
would be this one si si si si si si si
si si si si and then this one would be
re - no no I cannot dammit I thought my
idea was golden but no because of course
they don't need the gap for the grass
got it okay new design pattern let's go
boss let's just do these corner ones to
start with it'll be fine
great love it and then we go the
thickness is four but it's fine a
foreign because the grass is on the
outside yes correct do this
it's three the whole way where do I put
the line here
no um I don't want it halfway I wanted
at the bottom of the square right here
right right right and that would be the
first one no it has to be too thick
I'm pretty sure this is correct and then
I will make another one at the bottom
that will meet is this correct
right I did it I think yes I think this
is right
okay okay okay yeah you are going to be
weep
let's put weeb here
cool great button get we've put weeb
here yes and then we make the anti weave
here which is gonna be again X fill X
pen white it's still this way foreign
that's wrong but who cares okay
and then at the top we make - I believe
it and tie we I think this is gonna be
right is I'm gonna use the square once
that's it's a real gut punch when that
happens okay here we go beautiful
yeah yeah and then the middle is just
gonna be a line I'm having a whole from
scratch though so like if I think this
one is just gonna be this changed design
designs these [ __ ] suckles I'm gonna
kill me think I don't need a suckle yet
it's fine we'll figure it out let me
just test this theory that it's gonna be
that and then whomp and then whomp nuyk
nuyk nuyk nuyk uh no we need just it
just the two probably should have done
that that way but I should have done two
on either side that's my bad easy it
phone lines yes
this is gonna be showy we're just gonna
throw to Shelley's down Shirley I think
great just a nice symmetrical line yeah
we just put a nice symmetrical line I
get his ass
[ __ ] because it's in the center of so
many I have to make to show Lee's
they're both just lines to thickness
stupid game Charlie's useless Charlie's
gone
Charlie's gone and then we just do two
lines at the top I should've changed my
pen thickness I keep pressing white Oh
xxxx Nelly said to at the top
that circle is not gonna be big enough
if I'm placing this year the circle is
gonna be too small potentially I could
maybe make it work all right okay
the ante surely is going to be on the
bottom two thick-set no one ever
all right good stuff great across bottom
bottom good with the chat like to name
this I don't want to name her aunty
surely just give her a nice lady's name
you know we've got some Kwan's we've got
Jimmy's we've got James's Who am I
what's that what am I gonna call her
what am I gonna call her oh thank you
tonic toaster the reason the cam is in
the bottom center is because I was
covering stuff up so I was just throwing
it really pole I like pole no well we
did one a woman's name Susan and he does
anyone have like a nice like grandma
Mildred's a good one I'm a fan of
Mildred Miranda
Karen mom is also good Freya
so far I'm partial to Mildred I feel
like it matches a Shirley you know I'm
saying Ellen all Candace
Dorothy's good too Maeve yeah mmm
alright Michael will go with Gertrude
big fan let's do it Michael from YouTube
chat named good Gertrude here we go goat
rude and Shelley seemed like they would
be friends I buy it
done okay
good II didn't call I go through them so
sorry I'm so sorry country here we go
let's [ __ ] do it you're gonna go
right here
no you know that's not what I wanted to
do again I'm in the way of the [ __ ]
thing
move out of the way I can't I mean I
could move this up here that's fine okay
that's yeah let's get this good [ __ ]
good [ __ ] okay what what is the middle
of this [ __ ] thing look like am I
going to be able to make this in that
space it's pretty small that's gonna be
yeah if that's caught it right so we're
gonna have full of squares in the center
one two three four it's six squares
actually yeah okay [ __ ] this is gonna be
really hard it is gonna have to be six
though
I think it's gonna suck people squares
32 pixels I feel like um I answered I
read that out loud like it was helpful
are you sure it's on the post where's
one two three four
no I think you're right so be centered
and then it'll be but that means that
each hmm I'm not sure I'm just not sure
back I'm just covering the time for
anyone who would like to know it is
Saturday May 9th at 10:37 p.m. and now I
have not time traveled in this game okay
so now I have to make another one of
these [ __ ]
um which what did I call you before it's
too I did have to make two oh my god am
i running out of custom squares that's a
thing that can happen you can run out of
custom design areas I have to make the
anti weaves the official auntie weeps
[ __ ] okay let's do it
you stupid you punk you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] of a video game
which is again on the left side the
whole way up it's foreign
and then it's full right right right
yeah and then depending on list so we're
doing the top one it's just too great I
think that's right this is going to be
Reginald you I think a correct but I'll
find out when I lay down right here for
a Reginald
not you've got rude you've had your day
great brilliant okay let's do it
yeah yeah yeah same thing but bottom
okay yep good yeah now that is what I
wanted and then it's still this side or
in full thick I'm learning wouldn't the
anti we've just be a functional adult
okay question about the meaning of weed
though who else at a guest account
we've his antisocial stays inside
watches anime plays video games I
basically do that for a living
does that make me a professional weeb
think about it I'm arguably a functional
adult okay
chat who's hanging out with Reginald I
would like you to tell me who's hanging
out with Reginald it's got to be a nice
old man I don't know what they chat
about but they all hanging out it has to
be Japanese centric so you can only be a
weeb if you're actually Japanese is that
true
who Edgar's good I like Edgar Phil
Charles also very good Tyler ooh
Cornelius great work Eric Aramis Zeke I
know opposed I'm cold Zeke otaku's anime
specific oh we biz just you're right
sorry sorry I was thinking about I've
talked a weeb is just someone who's
obsessed with Japanese [ __ ]
Anton Archibald also good Virgil I like
Virgil he made me think of agile Van
Dyck Balthazar you guys are great at
this
Oswald let's go Oswald I like that
Congrats to denote Oswald K we [ __ ]
good got your old dude names down pat I
was walled and Reginald hanging out
making pokémon gyms for though for their
lies that's what they that's what they
[ __ ] be all about Oswald here you go
just put your ass down you swanky little
[ __ ] okay see okay look things are
happening things are looking good now
with the [ __ ] now the duck he loots him
said for the ball so on the leftmost
column of a blank do four thick going
down from the middle line of four thick
from the top line
I think what I had okay I can show you
what I think I need to start with is I
think it begins with I feel like I've
spoken publicly about this I'm really
bad at maths this is a mathematical
conundrum look it starts with the line
in the middle which means no matter what
I start with two up here
oh but only halfway so it's not gonna be
up to here it's gonna be say this is and
then what am I gonna go like like this
like how do I that's the line that's
gonna sit in the middle of the circle
right right I'm on the right path
correct we pop it because in reference
it looks like this chuckles two squares
wide based on the train areas yeah I
think that I've got the well no I think
this the circle is to school yeah it is
yeah I think the actual size of the
circles will be correct so this so far
is right but the middle bit is blank so
we don't have anything here because
they'll have to be this one and then
another one that will only have the
right side top two okay
I don't think it's gonna be all the way
across I'd be starting bottom left
corner correct I'm starting on the
bottom left corner that's what this is
this is the line we need the two circles
to be in this from here right [ __ ] my
brain already hurts is it a perfect
circle it is a perfect circle because it
looks like
how does this work oh that's interesting
it is a perfect circle because it looks
like the it looks like a pokeball can
this be done like no no no no that's not
gonna be right the circle would have to
oh [ __ ] I have to draw basically like
the circle going down to here which how
can I do it oh I can move off to using
the circle tool okay okay if I can do
that that will help the circle needs to
be for thick though but that's fine well
why is that not even you don't love that
that's not even incorrect can I change
the thickness of this have I [ __ ] up
when my positioning is again I'm just
having to keep moving myself around to
you make myself small really okay [ __ ]
here we go so if it's like this right I
can't stretch it outside the viewable
area if I could that would be great
so how do I move it once I've done that
change palette line tool just this drag
does not oh I see okay
oh yes drag design drag design we want
to go this is very confusing well that
would be right for this small circle
wouldn't it no it has to be in
and I could
just erase everything else that doesn't
seem right
do the circle than add in fill pixels
whether need for aesthetics listen it's
not a full circle though that's the
problem I'm making a quarter of a circle
now keep editing I'm just gonna this is
this is all trash that we're trashing
all of it all right
I don't know that is the cycle tool
going to work I don't think it is
because this again we make one circle
that just lives from here to here okay
so maybe that will actually work if I
can make a circle in here
no it's flat my brain it's probably I
probably need to count this out but it's
probably like like that maybe one across
from that and then if I go to X and then
I move this oh did I not put that down
no yeah yeah the circle tool it's just
go like so okay I'm just gonna
demonstrate what my thought process is
place that and if we want to move that
with the move tool the first one is like
this but we need to make it bigger [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] my brain can't handle it full
circle then drag in a race okay let's
start with the full circle I'm just
gonna need all your help that's what's
gonna happen here because um I can't
even comprehend how to do this so a
circle tool lets go white we're gonna do
a full circle full [ __ ] circle that's
the biggest circle I can make which is
weird because it's already missing oh I
can make it from the outside disregard
undo I keep forgetting there's an undo
button okay we can make it from one
outside okay
that's full circle then why did you not
place there's something out a cycle tool
that's that some other move - let's
continue my brain - want that that yes
and then go X and that will stay yes
okay we have a full circle to make the
little suckle this makes sense to me
because that's gonna be like that right
no it'll be like there and then we would
erase everything else right yes that's
correct
I'm I'm pretty confident I'm right but
we have to erase everything else why so
this is the little suckle I think pretty
sure okay
little circle good to go which is why
again this part will just be to here
this is all good look I could copy the
pixels oh it also need to be double
thick am I just gonna have to do some
actual [ __ ] pics a lot here okay this
is the big one is the one I'm confused
about it starts here
hmm yeah I think I kind of just big
circle doesn't have a line them big
circle does have a one little circle
doesn't have a line so the line is for
big circle I need six squares you think
full thick circle your right the suckle
does need to be full thick okay let's do
that right now
just like what I'm reading of this chat
is just so confusing that was only three
wasn't it did I already [ __ ] it up
that's two two one one one one one one
no I've done goofed on this yes okay
I've made nope I've made that three
thick for the most part
[ __ ] [ __ ] it score up there and then
it's all just three one two one one okay
is that all four I think so
redo this I can't build the other circle
I could just use the circle tool four
times that was a good point I might have
[ __ ] that up so let me just undo a
bunch of it oh I can only undo one great
okay
my brain is hurting but I think that
thickness is maybe correct that's four
cross that's four across that's four
that seems like too many maybe that's
how is that like a million no I'm
starting to circle over I'm just gonna
paste it four times
goodbye circle we tried my brain Hut
okay circle tool White has to be a full
[ __ ] circle yep good yep done X oh
wait I can do the circle tool just that
many times myself couldn't I know I'm
moving it first I'm moving it fast
[ __ ] line okay that's correct
for the circle we erase everything I'm
not having a good time we start it's not
good can I even do this though like
again can I even make the big circle is
the big circle even [ __ ] possible to
make I don't know if it is that's the
problem I don't know if I can do it can
I make the big circle
I'm gonna move it in one block cause
you're moving at the whole image every
time yeah well do I have the option to
not do that oh you're right
yeah that will just make it again but I
can probably just do this over here oh
do I have to draw the whole circle no I
don't know I'm gonna have to destroy it
in blocks again but it's fine cuz it's
three so boom this will be correct no it
won't this will and this will the rest
of it we'll figure it out
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to freehand it on a
it's the same proportions of the little
circle just across the three other
quadrants well I mean it's a lot bigger
than the little circle is the problem we
know this is - I don't even circle
that's the problem 1 2 that's 4 1 2 3 1
2 3 1 2 3 mm not sure that's correct
nope don't know not sure okay
how to make big circle like oh it's so
much bigger than little circle you know
that's the problem it has to start from
this out corner I know that lunch and
meet all the way down here I think I
have to do like actual pics a lot like
math add the two thick rows across after
so the rest is symmetrical first okay if
you say so fam hey sure I mean can I
just copy like literally no I can't I
have to add it to three so for every
pixel in the small circle you make two
pixels in the outer cells so that would
be what wait how does that add up it
won't be wide enough six down okay you
know what I'm just gonna believe you
it's double right so one two three four
five six and then we'll move in and
we'll go one two three four five six
I'll move in and we'll go hang on a one
more and then one two three four and
then in and then one two three four and
then in why is it for you keep saying
four but why is it for wouldn't it be
double if it's double the quadrants
why is it for because to what what
you've just said because dude
but this is three so what I'm trying to
double is the three and you're saying
two times two is four but it's three
that I'm trying to double this is three
I know that two times two is full but
I'm trying to times three why am I not
six and then four there's a but it's
it's so it's six and then it's six and
then it's four and then it's four yeah
the two becomes four that's what I did
this is for cuz it's - it's for what
it's do I mean someone can post a
template but I don't know that it's
gonna help ok so then this one I'm just
gonna keep going with my theory I'm up -
this is gonna be - this is gonna be -
this is gonna be - this is gonna be -
this doesn't seem right that's - one two
three okay no this one is not
- in fact [ __ ] it seems like it's
dragging too low it's the problem that's
not a circle
something's not right [ __ ] three one two
three four five six one oh I did one too
many on this one didn't I one two three
one
[Music]
I didn't know what's happened I'm not
Dublin on the x-axis so what do I need
to like double the amount that I'm going
in as well look after you guys told me
that I needed to do fall because it was
double six I like I mean double three I
don't trust you now okay all I know is
I'm pretty sure that's right and then
the bottom okay let's just start here
will be six at the bottom as well okay
one two three four five six is it that I
need to go two up probably
doubling every axis which means that yet
so it's two every time right again I
feel like I just don't trust you now
that you've told me that I needed to
double something to make it full when I
didn't okay so if we go to in is what
you're saying this would be another six
I'm just going to try it well oh wait
but is it six from here or is it six no
six from eight one two three four five
six and then this would be the same
we're just doing it one up one two three
four five six this seems to be working
for my brain better when I do it from
different angles so this one maybe four
one two three four this one would be
four one two three four well they're
equal so far so that's good and then
it's another four one two three four one
two three four and then it's just two
mmm that looks good yeah yeah I think
that looks like a circle sort of it's
very flat on the outsides but once I
thickened it the top left is offset by
one what do you mean by that that needs
to be one in what's the minor pixel
mistake what is it yeah I think I just
need to make it I have a line of seven
on the top left one two three four five
six oh well if you're looking at this
one it doesn't really count because they
will just join that's why that looks
that way right like they're all going to
just do this I think that's still
technically just a line of one two three
four five six if I were to remove that
but I think that's right
the second lift is too long I don't
think it is man top right needs to be
three not six why would it be three and
not six I don't understand what you're
telling me why would it be three and not
six and also if it's three then how do I
move everything else
why would it be that I don't think I
think you're wrong this was never seven
this is always six it's just that I had
one up here I think I'm just connecting
them all down all right okay
and then we just make a full thick one
two three one two three one two three
I mean it's got a lot smoother when I
put it down at the very least
wait is that fall yes the white cause
really [ __ ] me on this I really
shouldn't 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
oh they're not thick enough that's fine
fix it that's good because it's gonna be
thick out not in so that's gonna be that
way okay
yeah yeah here we go here we go here we
go it's this way
one two is that correct
but he's supposed to be the same
no I'll figure it out it's definitely
something wrong here right here
something's off but I don't know what it
is that looks that why is that five
thick
you're too thick fam never thought I'd
say it but I think you are and then this
is supposed to be because that's what's
supposed to be like that
yeah it's fixed at six it's it's one two
three four five six
yeah that's right right enough I think
it's good and then we just do the two
across right I think that's what our
lower left is supposed to look like this
sort of looks a bit [ __ ] up there to
mine what's happened to you why is that
that thick it's fall this will be it'll
be over four tiles which is why this is
mmm many bits that look wrong though mmm
don't forget about that no why am i
erased I've erased too much listen
here's the thing it's gonna look great
once we put it down but some of its not
right some of it's definitely not right
I don't need to soften it up by removing
the cornices once you like put it down
it'll look way softer the fourth row
should be three tiles in a small circle
the fourth row Toby this one you think
this should be three tiles why they're
all full it's only three stick at once
quotas other problem which one is only
three sick I can't see where it is I
can't see where the error is
yeah it looks blocking in the preview
but once it's down on the ground it'll
look even cuz that's how it works
no it generally doesn't look the way it
does on the Left canvas but if it does
that's a bum Oh which means it like this
is if I'm trying to make the left canvas
then I want to remove that probably that
and then that that and that looks more
circular maybe add that back in but I
feel like if you put it on the ground
it's usually even blurry oh right
because if that's it then this is wall
way off there's too many people throwing
numbers at me and a lot of them have
been wrong the diagonal of the big
circle is missing a pixel yeah I know
this is not me three thick now but it
looks better like it shouldn't be though
I should be it needs to be four it does
need to be four
but I don't want to put it down here cuz
it'll [ __ ] up you know I could fix it on
the other one no fill in for down left 6
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 6 disagree that I
should fill that in cut top left and
bottom right by 3 top left this and
bottom right are you sure this is too
many numbers I feel like the this part I
should maybe not do on stream just sit
down and figure it out
try using sand colored shade at the
corners of the big circle to force it to
smooth out and the jagged edge will
blend with the sand no it won't yeah I'm
just gonna leave it for now and we'll
put it on the ground and we'll figure it
out you know
can i smooth the the big suckle out I
don't know that I can I mean I could
like just erase some pixel and see what
happens this is too thin it shouldn't be
this thing that's we need to [ __ ]
chuck a circle in here somewhere for
some reason but I don't know where I
would put it well not there nope mmm I
want to just get rid of some of the
corners right I can just do that [ __ ] I
think I can smooth this out you know I
think this is doable [ __ ] I wish I could
just copy and rotate them though like if
I'm doing all of this that smoothes [ __ ]
out a bit just you get rid of some of
these chunky corners cuz it is bigger
what's going on down here [ __ ] hell
okay it's getting smooth out but I'm
worried I'm just undoing all my hard
work yeah cool weird circle you've got
here fam yep smooth that look okay it's
smoother than it was but it's not the
right thickness at all and it also
doesn't look like a circle now it looks
like a corner make the center of the big
circle more thick the center of the big
circle what do you even mean by that it
was always squiggly let's be real it was
always squiggly it was never not
squiggly but now I guess these parts are
too thin cuz these are only three across
so let's just [ __ ] do some of this
[ __ ] I know that like mathematically
a circle needs to be actually even which
it you know what I'm just gonna put it
on the ground we're gonna call it maybe
a circle
not sure it's only part of a circle
anyway right maybe a circle question
mark oh here we go
who knows could be not a circle it's
fine I will make it work we will figure
it out over time but I am gonna stop
streaming after putting this [ __ ] down
I will figure it out
off stream and then I will upload a
video showing you all how this [ __ ]
looks are you ready boom pokeball who
actually looks better than expected it's
not smooth but and it's definitely too
sharp but actually with it not being
smooth I'm I'm even fine with that
because it almost suits the out outer
edge corners it's not that bad it's not
that bad it could have been worse I
agree it works with the texture of the
ground it's like the sand made it wobbly
you know and then if I just put three
more of these in this he'll the inner
does look better than the outer that's
true but that's causing in as less
pixels yeah it is
obviously well I doubted you because you
lied to me several times and like a lot
of you like so many of you lied that you
know I thought that maybe something you
were saying would be right because I was
like look at the frequency of people
that are telling me two times two is
full and I'm like [ __ ] I know but I'm
trying to double three which is six you
know you know so it's different it's
supposed to be chalk which is always
grainy that's fit that's better
I just have to do that several more
times
I'll figure it out two times two wasn't
correct at that point it was three times
two it was six some of you have helped
look I'm not gonna say you didn't but
some of you definitely just lied yeah
you kind of can't just use circles to
make chuckles it the app I don't think
walks like that I wish I could copy
paste and flip but you can't write you
can't write how long is it taking to get
to this point I mean in terms of like my
entire island this is taken 150 hours or
so
I know you can do it online but I kind
of want to do it in game you can copy
and flip the entire design are you sure
in the editor in the game I don't know
if that's true but this has taken me the
length of this dream probably less it's
probably taken about an hour to do what
I've done here so far but I'm also very
bad at it
I'm excited about how it's shaping up
there we're gonna change those outside
custom designs to look different they're
gonna look like like they actually do
look on this you make it like a
different kind of stone with the black
only outside but doing squares is like
white [ __ ] easier than it goddamn
suckle my nemesis just the worst but
look I'll figure it out I'll do it and
then I'll get back to you guys and then
you'll see it when it's done and
hopefully everyone will be very excited
when I do my actual island to it I'm too
ambitious you know that's the problem
are you gonna see this in a funhouse
video no this will be a video on my
personal channel
okay if I can mirror it that would be
very hidden I don't know that I can look
I'm not sure you're right
does the gym have a theme I mean not
really but if anything it would probably
be water just because it's surrounded by
ordering this the waterfall there and
it's like right next to the beach but
yeah it's just a place to battle
pokemons you know you know how it'd be
that's pretty much it when I try
mirroring it right now okay let's just
try that before I leave get maybe a
circle what change design change design
I guess is there a copy option in here
somewhere
what do i what am I supposed to do this
is no math I'm just I just want to copy
this how do I copy it
ah why swap slash copy copy and then I'm
going here you delete it
okay then I'm opening this I'm going
change design and then I'm trying to
flip it
mm-hmm swap preview that okay that
activated mirror mode how do I know no
it's not that
so how do I flip it change design press
X mm-hmm uh-huh and now change palette
no pen in line to the rectangle feel
like I know this does mirror but then
what
I don't think you can I think you're
lying to me I didn't think it was
possible mm-hmm how do I flip fam you
told me I could see you [ __ ] tell me
how to do it
mmm I suddenly went very quiet I didn't
think you could yeah I'm sure there's
plenty of missing pixels man I'll fix it
I guess there's one missing
yeah well Marimo it helps you me refer
for drawing purposes
that's what Mira does I don't think you
can flip all the people saying flip are
suddenly very quiet you guys click why
on this screen okay click on why nothing
happening the chat is a house of lies
you're right you all lied I didn't think
so [ __ ] don't lie to me
I told you it wasn't possible yeah
Mara lets you draw on both sides at once
in case you want to draw something
that's symmetrical but you totally can't
flip a design you're full of [ __ ]
there's so many of them saying that no I
knew you couldn't which is a bummer but
it is what it is maybe a circle we're
just gonna add one pixel we're just
gonna add one pixel that I saw that was
missing which is right here oh did I
remove that to smooth it though because
if I did then respect yeah I did
no that's that's well it [ __ ] it I'm not
touching it anymore it's no it's done
it's done I'm not doing it it's done
I'll figure it out and then I will
return to you okay
I'm positive I have to hand make them
all right I know it's it's all right
I'll do it
it'll look beautiful I'm okay with it
being fuzzy because yeah I think that
works for the sand it's fine we're gonna
be fine we're gonna be just fine my
brain doesn't walk well with this
specific kind of thing but it's gonna
look done I'll show you guys when it's
done thank you for joining this is fun
I'll be very stupid stream but I had a
good time so I appreciate your help like
I said as soon as it's done I will
update you guys which is probably gonna
be sometime this week and I will show
you the full gosh-dang island I'll do it
- uh it's five stars or about 200 hours
in probably not quite that far I think
I'm gonna 1 150 maybe but yeah thank you
all for joining me have a wonderful
night I appreciate your help even the
liars I appreciate you too you know you
were full of [ __ ] but we had a good time
we learned Animal Crossing sucks